hi I'm Troy Bond and I am here to answer
the internet uh what is the fiercest
animal you think you could take on in a
fight pictured is a beaver an ostrich
and an owl definitely not an owl because
they just can keep coming back air
advantage you're [__] you can't get an
ostrich uh I don't think so although I
see this woman on Tick Tock like there's
an ostrich is always trying to kill her
she just sticks her hand out and it
stops and he's just looking at her like
all right [__]
yeah
I thought this was a fight yeah
[Laughter]
I'm looking at this beaver and he looks
like he's not ready to take me in a
fight it just looks like he's like oh I
didn't know we were fighting tonight I
thought I had another week to train
I could definitely take beavers uh I
wouldn't want to fight a duck but I
could probably or Goose geese are
[__] I'm not [__] with him yeah
can you still go to your Barber if he is
very racist uh my barber is very racist
I don't even know what he looks like he
wears a hood
he's probably bald
but uh oh this one has it oh my God
someone drew the graphic of a klansman
going to a barber I didn't even listen
when you find someone who cuts your hair
like exactly how you like it yeah
there's not much I would let no stop
yeah listen easy the running Fades or
catching fades it depends on what kind
of rallies he's going to who's the one
person in the world you would least want
to bang your significant other Caitlyn
Jenner without it
yes because she just pick a side Caitlyn
yeah right I don't want you scissoring
my girl if you're out here being all
anti-trans rights do you know what side
of the aisle you're shopping on because
uh you might want to take a look at your
cart there she sure got out right in
time off my golf course baby get him out
of here it's gross
ew what is your stance on washing your
hands after taking a piss uh listen
everybody I think we could all pretend
that not every you know no one's really
doing it all the time I just peed and I
could lie to you and say I wash my hands
I can tell you the truth and tell you I
wash my hands
uh I think uh post covered if it doesn't
matter I think we were all gonna die
once we had to start singing happy
birthday to wash our hands you know what
is pee anyway it's a little piss on your
head if you pee on your hands yes you
got bigger yeah like if you yeah I would
say you should do it but it's also one
of those things like you know people
sometimes drink and drive and make it
home
yeah
you ever hear about those stories
I'm not condoning it I'm just saying it
happens
which NFL team would win all white
players or all black players it depends
on who how racist their Barber is
I would say all black players without a
doubt now if we're talking which
lacrosse team all white players all day
every day either way it's all white
coaches
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
Aliens who would it be oh man you got to
think like I don't know why the first
person that comes to my head is the rock
a lot of people it's almost like a
social experiment a lot of people say
the Rocks yeah like I I I think he's
just a perfect face for either him or
Trump because both represent parts of
humanity like I think Trump should be
the mascot for America forget the bald
eagle he's America you put him up here
on the McDonald's arches that's where I
save you Trump or the rock I would want
to meet the aliens because then they'd
probably leave us alone we're not
threatened by you would you rather [__]
the hottest girl celebrity who has a
dick or Vin Diesel with a [__] I'll
pick either I don't care just give me a
little friction a little heat boys let's
get this party started why are we
playing checkers I'm on a chess board
um
yeah that's about the love and spreading
it and whatever other diseases
sick with a dick is just two of my
favorite things ice cream on a steak my
friends ice cream on a steak let's go
what are we doing playing Samantha's
Turn the Page and start a new chat if
every time you got a boner the same song
would start playing what song would you
want Imperial March Darth Vader's theme
song
every single time every time that man
like that's ominous boner in the world
and I would feel suspicious every time I
got one like I think that's what happens
when you're Catholic and you get a bone
yeah something's evil and I don't like
it and I'm guilty that or My Humps how
many rats would it take to overwhelm you
and kill you in a fight one I'm so
terrified of rats there's a mouse in my
apartment right now and we can't find
him he's so smart like I just see tail
and ass and I'm terrified of rice when I
was a kid I was attacked by a mouse the
size of a grizzly bear I used to have to
go uh like feed my dog and I went under
the sink to grab the dog food and it
just jumped out at me and I I think he
was just as terrified as me then he ran
into the basement I never went into that
basement ever yeah my brother could have
been drowning down there in a flood I'd
be like rip buddy now I know you and
them also both gone I could continue to
play Playstation in peace this flossing
in public acceptable
only if you're the one doing it if
anyone else does it it's just a great
answer it's like taking your shoes off
of the airplane I can do it I don't want
to see you do it who the [__] do you
think you are I am the main character
here you understand that right would you
rather have your dick as your nose or
your nose as your dick well listen
I'm passionate level ladies and uh
they've both been in the same place
downstairs
I wouldn't want to have a
dick on my nose but I only because I was
thinking I wouldn't want to smell it but
I wouldn't because it wouldn't have your
nose yeah yeah but sex would have I mean
that'd be hard I'd probably get Whiplash
I've seen now it's like two minutes
pick those masks so I have to cover it
that's the thing
yeah I'm gonna be anti-mass because I
want my dick to be free out of this
would you I know my answer uh would you
rather have a flaccid dick or a hard
dick on your nose like in your face
possible hard I want to show off all the
time yeah
you're gonna be talking like Zoidberg
would you take
would you take four million dollars to
be caught on To Catch a Predator yeah I
would but I would do it like so clearly
to let him like I would just be like
yeah yeah enough talk when can I come
get the pizza
I feel like yeah I wouldn't even be like
all right yeah you're hot whatever for a
12 year old what
half pineapple no pepperoni extra cheese
tell Chris I'll be there at six it's
great exposure like they still make
YouTube videos of those guys they can't
go anywhere else but I know that and
they did it I'm from Connecticut they
did it like two towns over for me so I I
didn't know anybody that was on it but
that put Connecticut on the map yeah the
catch Predators out there they don't
catch a single person on opioids which
is way easier to do because they don't
move as much I would I would take the
four million it depends on what I'm
caught doing I guess being a predator
I guess once you say it out loud
who is the worst group of fans I have to
go with uh and it's it sucks because you
know they're my own kind and I hate them
I'm like a black Republican but it's
Star Wars fans they're the worst fans on
Facebook I am one of them I've grown up
with everything they hate everything and
and they just not happy now there's so
much stuff out there they're like
they're just over exhausting this and
I'm getting tired of watching all this
stuff so don't watch it go outside and
watch some [__] dog a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away you might get
laid
go have a good time don't worry about
what club cheeto's doing go on the fun I
hate them so much Marvel fans are
getting there for me too it's almost
right here Marvel is actually almost the
opposite for me I feel like I've seen
like they love everything that comes out
I'm like bro yeah that movie sucks
that's the thing that bodies are totally
average now did we watch the same
Ant-Man yeah come on man that that the
scene at the end where Kang beat the
[__] out of his girlfriend was crazy wow
Marvel's really going for it
what is a little thing someone can do
that actually makes them a crazy person
letting a dog kiss you on the mouth oh
my god oh I can't do it like as soon as
I see that sex is off the table Terry I
don't want to get sloppy seconds I can't
do it dogs lick their ass if I could I
would I didn't want to go from ass to
mouth that way I'm an old Christian
fella all right if I'm doing it it's
going to be with my nose I'm a dick
would you rather
[__] yourself every time you come get a
boner every time you talk to a dude
who's to say these aren't already
happening boners are exhausting man
because like you you ever like in bed
and like you start to get hard and
you're like man I could either I should
just go to bed right now but then he's
just like anyways
um I feel like that would be like if I'd
be so exhausted and have nothing left
after today if I was hard the whole time
this pocket every two seconds guys I
gotta go to that I feel like the sixth
time would be like it's like an empty
shampoo
I would say [__] myself every time I
come because I can control that and yeah
yeah I mean you can control how much I
can control where I [__] and where I
come back where's the bathroom where's
the bathroom oh my God not another
episode of Baywatch
I watch Baywatch on tape that's how much
of a creep I am nothing does it for me
anymore porn has been ruined I need to
[__] and come watching Pamela Anderson
knowing what I know now
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out